which colleges might you advise your
sons to attend if they wanted a liberal
education
unconstrained by critical theory how
might you advise them to communicate
with those
thus constrained well i think this is a
good time
to talk about cryogenics and the
possibility that you may want to put
your children into cold storage
until we have generated a new academy
that doesn't suck
quite so much um
is that the wrong answer because that's
certainly so i don't i i like the
question i obviously
resurrected it from last week but i
don't have an answer
uh you know until two years ago or so i
was saying university of chicago it's
the it's the first it's standing strong
etcetera but um there's plenty to
indicate that
chicago itself is uh cracking from
within
in many regards um
yeah i do i do not have a good answer at
this point
uh the truly experimental colleges
um are likely to be
just as royal by this evergreen was one
of them yep
and the
you know i think unfortunately the sort
of the state schools like the ag schools
and such
um or the schools that were originally
um land-grant colleges
uh are like everywhere the science
departments are going to fall last
and maybe the art departments as well
but
the people being hired out of
phd programs in many of the social
sciences and humanities at this point
those fields are so captured so
corrupted
that i don't know how you would hire
faculty
um that don't have this this virus
in them so you know you if
if you know what field you're interested
in studying and frankly i don't think
it's a great idea to know at 18 to be
certain that you really know what it is
that you want to be studying you should
be
trying to be a generalist at that point
but if you really have a sense of like i
want to do
you know architecture or literature or
chemistry or whatever it is
potentially looking sorry i mean this is
like the opposite advice i would have
given 10 20 years ago but
looking for a department with older
faculty
faculty who may have been
may have at least gotten through their
own academic training
before this was quite so pervasive uh
might be one one approach but that
doesn't that doesn't address the fact
that administrators
i did some research a couple years ago
it's published on
as a piece called on college presidents
in which i looked at the
uh the demographics of college
presidents
from a survey that's been sent out since
the 70s every six to 10 years or so
and the the academic fields
to which college presidents belong has
been skewing more and more
towards exactly these fields that are
more and more woke
and that's more true unfortunately
the less elite the institution is and so
the r1s the you know the big research
granting universities especially the
ones whose names everyone knows
are more likely to have someone at the
helm who you know might be a scientist
and the community colleges are more
likely to have people
frankly who got their degrees their
higher degrees their terminal degrees
from
ed schools and schools of ed are well
captured
yeah i mean i think in some sense this
battle is over
and um the
the trajectory is very clear there's
nothing on the horizon
that solves this you know academia was
first to fall
it is the most deeply corrupted of
the institutions i think and ultimately
something will replace it or it will be
resurrected
but that's not on the horizon so
i think i would separate the question
into two things why are you going to
college
you're going to college to get a degree
because you need it that might change
to the extent of the people who come out
of colleges will be
lobotomized by the insanity that's going
on there
presumably employers will wise up and
stop requiring it and maybe even prefer
people who
didn't do that and then there's the
question
of what you will do to substitute for
what you would have learned
in college and the answer is that you
can do a lot about
right there's a ton you can do to get
the equivalent of a college education
without attending college or paying for
it so if we can separate those two
things
and correctly read the tea leaves that a
college education is not going to be
mandatory in a world where
what passes for college education is
subscribing to [ __ ]
um you know yeah you can at least just
limit yourself to the second question
which is how am i gonna end up
with um skills and insight that uh
i'm gonna need and that you can do on
your own so just to summarize your point
you there's a credentialing issue and
there's an actual skills and knowledge
issue
and they are increasingly separable
absolutely and your tools for sourcing
your own
uh knowledge insight and skills are
better than ever
right the number of things people will
teach you on youtube is incredible if
you can figure out how to
sort the wheat from the chaff uh the
next question is related would you
consider off would you
consider offering online courses with
zoom lectures syllabus writing
assignments etc i believe many would pay
market tuition
so we've thought about something like
this in the past and it's still
you know it's still a possibility uh
it's not an active project at the moment
but but we have thought about
uh we've certainly thought about
actually doing um
field trips extended field trips that
include curriculum in advance and
yeah yeah i think field trips would be
the most natural for us the most
fun and interesting yeah um but from the
point of view of offering something that
uh you know college 2.0 um there is that
that idea is definitely live even though
the project is at the moment not
so can we promise if we do decide to do
field trips that no one has to eat macaw
um you know it depends if things go
really wrong
yeah no problem yeah sure all bets are
off but we'll do everything we can
i mean macaw is well above cannibalism
true yeah yeah
yeah and we want no none of the paying
customers will be my cause so we'll keep
that line
really bright yeah i gotta say i think
that that
uh that pattern will carry over from the
past into the future almost no matter
what
[Music]
true
[Music]
you